hey what is up everybody its Anna Mack
here for anime uproar and today I will
be talking about something that I've
been seeing a lot lately both on YouTube
and on social media rumors are swirling
and a lot of people are speculating that
the current arc in volcano hero manga or
the arc after this one could be the
final arc in the entire series the rumor
is that the MHA manga is ending and
ending a lot sooner than we might think
so
is this possible is there any truth to
these rumors or is it just internet
conjecture that is what I will be
talking about in this video
Before we jump into it a big thank you
to hero cantata for sponsoring this
video
hero cantare is a brand new hero
collector RPG created in collaboration
with webtoon so that means that your
favorite heroes from webtoon series like
tower of god god of high school and
hardcore leveling warrior get
transported to another world together
you guys know that I love Tower of God
and it was actually so cool to be able
to use bomb as one of my favorites but
even more than bomb I absolutely love my
tower of God waifu yuri ha and she isn't
this game as well she is absolutely
beautiful and badass and of course she
is my favorite hero enjoy the high
quality 2d animation the epic gaming
soundtrack and great rewards for
downloading the game including bomb Jin
Mori and a hard leveling warrior as
in-game characters ten summons half a
million in gold and more the latest
update is bringing ten popular
characters from the noblesse Universe
into the game including rise L Sarah
Frankenstein and música there will be a
special hero dungeon featuring their
story and if you log on during the
two-week collaboration you will receive
any noblesse SS hero of your choice
check it out for yourself just click the
link in the description and enjoy this
awesome gaming webtoon crossover bonus
hero cantare is now offering a free
limited time giveaway of a $50 Amazon
gift card click the link in the
description for a chance to win if you
enjoyed the pocono here content on this
chain
you want us to keep it going please
leave a like to let me know it really
does help and if you happen to be new to
the channel or you just haven't
subscribed please consider subscribing
and hitting that notification bell heads
up this video will of course contain
boku no hero manga spoilers we are
talking about the very latest arc in the
manga so please proceed with caution you
have been warned
now if you're an anime only you won't
have any idea what I'm talking about
when I say that the series might be
ending and that is because the boku no
hero manga is just so far ahead of the
anime by the time that the MHA anime
comes back on air the manga is likely
going to be well over 100 chapters ahead
of the anime and that is a huge amount
of content a lot has changed in the
story since the point in which the anime
left off the epic encounter between
endeavour and the high-end nomal there
has been a ton of character development
and a ton of power development since
that time and at this point in the story
it really does look like we are
approaching some sort of final showdown
the stakes are so incredibly high the
powers of the heroes and the villains
are through the roof and some pretty
important characters are in danger of
losing their lives actually a bunch of
characters already did lose their lives
both on the villains side and on the
heroes side if you're caught up to the
manga then you know exactly where we are
Shigure Aki has just become an
overpowered monster the like of which
the heroes have never seen before not
only did he fully awaken his own quirk
decay which now allows him to level
entire city blocks with only a single
touch but he has also just inherited the
quirk all for one and not only did he
inherit all for one itself he also
inherited a whole bunch of other quirks
that the villain known as all for one
had stolen over the course of his
criminal career and this includes super
regeneration search air blasts radio
waves and who knows how many more we
literally do not know how many quirks
shigaraki currently possesses and if
that wasn't crazy enough shigaraki has
already demonstrated that he can
effectively use and combine these new
works on the battlefield since she got a
keys so new to using all for one and all
the different stolen quirks we would
have been forgiven for thinking that
maybe she got a key we'll need some time
to learn to use all of these new quirks
not to mention learning to combine them
in order to create new compound quirk
attacks if that had been the case if she
got a key needed to train for a certain
period of time in order to harness the
full power of all-4-one then we would
have known for sure that the series
wouldn't be ending anytime soon she got
a key would need a lengthy training arc
to unlock and master all of his new
quirks and in the meantime Deku and the
heroes would be training to in
particular deck who would have the
chance to unlock the rest of the quirks
that are hidden inside one for all
before he and shigaraki finally engaged
in an epic final showdown however the
fact that she got a key is already
proficient at using all for one just
minutes after awakening from logical
procedure seems to support the theory
that boku no hero could be ending sooner
rather than later
in fact upon his awakening she greggy's
main goal is to take one for all away
from Deku all for one himself was never
strong enough to steal one for all even
if he wanted to but we have been led to
believe that the new fully awakened
shiko dachi has the ability to actually
steal it
Fujiko excruciatingly procedure has
apparently made his body strong enough
to withstand the assimilation of one for
all and so if she got a key does succeed
in stealing one for all on top of all
the other stolen quirks that he
possesses it would pretty much be game
over for the heroes the big question is
can she gareki actually take one for all
when we have been led to believe that
one for all can only be given up
willingly is it possible that after all
this time all for one a new G code just
simply weren't aware that one for all
can't be stolen or did the villains
figure out a way to force Deku to give
up one for all I don't know exactly how
this might happen perhaps she gareki now
possesses some sort of mind manipulation
quirk that can compel Deku to give up
one for all or perhaps she gareki is
just planning to hold someone hostage
and threaten to kill them unless dec who
gives up one for all
willingly knowing deku and how badly he
wants to save people I wouldn't be
surprised if he is prepared to give up
one for all in order to save the life of
someone he cares about but whether one
for all can be taken by shigaraki or not
he is definitely going to try to take it
and that is currently leading him right
into a face-to-face confrontation with
Deku that means that the main
protagonist of the entire series is
Akuma Daria will be facing off against
the newly overpowered leader of the
villains
Tamura shigaraki in that sense the
battle between the two of them really
does feel like a potential final
showdown and that's not all she got a
key is now so powerful that he has
already devastated an entire city and
killed some top tier pro heroes like
cross then who knows how many others the
damage that she Guara he has caused is
so extensive that we don't actually know
which heroes died and which heroes
survived beyond that shigaraki isn't
even the only threat that the heroes
have to worry about
giganto macchia dobby toga and other
villains are headed to the very same
place where she Guara ki is currently
located so not only are we going to see
shigaraki vs. Deku but we're also going
to see the strongest villains taking on
the strongest heroes in that same
location when we take all of that into
consideration it really does feel like
horikoshi is setting up a major final
battle between all the most opie
villains and heroes
not to mention that endeavor the number
one pro hero is already there and
fighting against shigaraki since we know
that dobby is on his way here as well he
was summoned by shigaraki it is possible
that the big confrontation between
endeavor and Dhabi and dobby's big
identity reveal may also take place in
this very arc so again I can understand
why some people believe that all of the
pieces are falling into place and that
this arc could turn out to be the big
epic climax of the entire series the
newly overpowered shiitake is directly
targeting Deku so this will likely push
that ghoul to unlock the remaining one
for all quirks much sooner than he would
have been able to otherwise and as a
result we get to witness the incredible
battle to the death between two
completely broken character
the main protagonist versus the main
villain one for all versus all for one
the symbol of peace versus the symbol of
evil and so on so to be fair to the
rumors
this latest boku no hero war Arc
definitely seems like a setup for a
potential final showdown between the
heroes and the villains it's hard to
imagine how the stakes could be any
higher in any future arc since we
already have top tier heroes dying
cities being destroyed extremely
overpowered villains and so on and
that's all well and good but does any of
this really mean that boku no hero is
about to end in an arc or two well no it
doesn't and I don't think that the
series will end all together but the end
of this arc whatever it ends up being
will definitely be an ending of sorts
it will signal the end of the hero
society as we know it with the villains
being so overpowered and with so many
heroes dying and with more major deaths
likely on the way the tone of boku no
hero has already shifted dramatically
and in my opinion there will be no going
back to normal the world of boku no hero
has gotten darker and none of the heroes
and hero students will ever be the same
after the events of this arc
what's more the entire Japanese hero
society and the people of that society
as a whole will never be the same either
faith in the Pro heroes and their
ability to protect the citizens of Japan
is about to collapse when they see top
tier heroes being eliminated an entire
city blocks being leveled by the
villains the people of Japan will face a
crisis of faith with all might retired
and no one yet being able to take his
place as the definitive symbol of peace
in the immediate future there is sure to
be a lot more chaos panic and disorder
all over Japan even if the villains lose
this battle the threat of them
regrouping and repeating what happened
to jakku hospital and the surrounding
area will always be on the minds of the
people and so the trust in the heroes
ability to stop the villains will be
greatly reduced and if the villains
actually win this battle
if they manage to push the heroes back
or you
and forced them to leave Japan and
regroup in another country the
consequences for society as a whole will
be even more dire we could potentially
see all of Japan fall into the hands of
the villains we could see a global
heroes vs. villains conflict and we
could see absolute chaos on the streets
as everyday people are caught up in this
massive war my main point is this
obviously we don't know what exactly is
going to happen by the end of this epic
war arc but judging by what has happened
so far no matter what happens next
things will never be the same for the
hero society with she Gaddafi's new
abilities and with everything that he
has been able to accomplish already it
will be impossible to just go back to
the way things were
do I really think that the entire boku
no hero series is going to end soon no I
don't think so the series is extremely
popular and horikoshi enjoys making it
and I believe that he will continue to
do so however the tone and themes of the
story and the Society of boku no hero
have already changed and there is no
going back to normal the villains and
heroes are currently engaged in an
all-out war and that war is not going to
end with just one battle this war will
continue and it will affect people
including the general public this war
will also lead to many casualties for
both the heroes and the villains and
even some of the most prominent
characters in the story like all might
Aizawa endeavor Gran Torino and Baku
goal could end up losing their lives
I predict that we might also get some
sort of significant time skip after this
arc a time skip that emphasizes just how
much the world has changed and just how
much the story has matured I mean just
think about it even if this battle ends
in a non decisive way and most of the
main characters survive does it really
make sense for deku and the others to
just go back to being normal high school
students while the new shigaraki is out
there roaming and plotting his next
attack back when the villains were far
less dangerous this made sense but now
that she got a key has unprecedented
levels of power and an entire villain
army behind him pretending like
everything is normal just won't work and
if she got a key decides to break into
and free all the other major villains
like all-4-one and stained things will
get even crazier even more quickly as I
said I don't think that this is the
final arc of boku no hero but I do think
that this is the end of boku no hero as
we know it things will change
drastically after this arc and that
includes the characters the society and
the tone of the entire story
we might get a time skip to further
emphasize this change and the heroes vs.
villains conflict will no longer be a
small scale skirmish it is now an
all-out war that will require major
sacrifices on both sides but let me know
what you guys think do you buy into the
rumors that MHA might be ending soon or
are you confident that the story is
going to keep going for the foreseeable
future also do you agree with my take
that even if the story continues the
nature of the hero society and the hero
will and conflict will never be the same
again
please share your thoughts down in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
and you want to see more boku no hero
content right here on the channel please
leave a like to let me know it really
does help and if you happen to be new to
the channel or you just haven't
subscribed yet please consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
oh I know it's annoying but if you don't
do that you're still gonna miss a lot of
our videos even if you subscribe it's
just how you do works don't forget to
check out our sponsor hero cantare
link in the description as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]